if the end of the world was upon us
would you be ready
today people all over america are
stocking extensive amounts of food water
and ammunition
expecting that at any moment a
devastating disaster will strike these
people are called preppers
i'm preparing for the second worldwide
great depression for the collapse of
society due to peak oil for a worldwide
pandemic
in the next hour we are going coast to
coast to meet the country's most extreme
preppers and get a first-hand look
inside their truly unbelievable
preparations tastes like frozen cricket
from massive secret bunkers this would
be a good place to be if chaotic things
are happening above ground and vast food
stockpiles one of my most super secret
hiding spaces that only i know about to
over the top defense systems
and have designed as a last recourse the
most intricate bug out plans pulling out
for some preppers this never before seen
footage might just mean the difference
between life and death come on with your
hands off
if the world as we know it is ending
they might just be the best prepared all
right boys let's go this is doomsday
preppers extreme prep edition bunkers
bullets and bug outs let's have fun
[Music]
survival experts from fema to practical
preppers know that to survive a major
disaster a substantial and secure
shelter is necessary
bunker sales increased as much as one
thousand percent for some companies in
two thousand eleven
but shelters can come in different
shapes and sizes designed with a variety
of purposes they can provide refuge for
days weeks months and even in the most
extreme cases years
it all depends on the individual
prepper's plan and budget
riley cook built a custom-made bunker
cut into the side of a mountain where
his family of five can hide for years
on the plains of kansas businessman
larry hall is building an underground
luxury apartment building to house
dozens
but ed and his wife diana currently live
in one of the most unusual and possibly
extreme doomsday bunkers
they bought a retired cold war era
missile silo formerly home to a four
megaton thermonuclear warhead
i am preparing to survive and thrive
underground
[Music]
we live in a decommissioned atlas e
missile site
it's a very large underground hardened
structure keeps us very safe from lots
of things the government spent four
million dollars to build this base in
1960
ed took it off their hands for forty
thousand dollars in the eighties
it has 18 inch walls built to withstand
a direct nuclear strike and a 400 ton
blast proof retractable roof sealing
them inside
but this military compound was renovated
for civilian use
ed and diana now make lunches where
soldiers once protected launch codes
the couple removed the cold war hardware
and turned this the former command
center into a kitchen
toast will be useful
okay good pleasant put the wind's down
okay
but preppers don't have to be quite so
radical living underground 24 7 or
extravagant spending 40 grand on a
missile silo to protect themselves
more than a million shipping containers
go into surplus each year
at approximately fifteen hundred to four
thousand dollars each they are an
affordable proper resource
on the texas plains vietnam vet paul
range and his partner gloria created a
fortress by stacking their containers
two stories high
vineyard owner mr wayne buried his
container five feet underground with the
cooler temperatures make it perfect for
food storage and use as a wine cellar
tim ralston plans to bury three shipping
containers to house 16 members of his
family he spent six months planning the
layout i'm preparing my family for the
total destruction of the power grid
shipping containers used to transport
commercial goods across the ocean can be
10 times stronger than a typical house
they are also rust corrosion and mildew
resistant
hello hey how you doing tim ralston how
you doing michael nice to meet you nice
to meet you michael i'm looking to buy
some containers the reason i chose a
shipping container is it's already got
all the reinforced walls we don't have
much time so it's kind of already
pre-fabbed for us all we're doing is
building out the insides so what are you
gonna be storing it me my family no we
don't have a lot of requests for for
burying containers to put your family in
and then i could do literally a bunk
here another bunk here i love this one
you know i love the extra the height so
i think this is the one
some preppers have different plans on
how to best use their bunkers
john major built a five by seven foot
concrete reinforced foxhole to create a
forward outpost to defend his home
against intruders
to protect his family barry buried a
steel pod under his garage that sleeps
four people for a maximum of 60 days
but doug huffman a retired defense
contractor has built a series of coffin
sized spider holes to defend his home
home sweet home
i'm preparing for the second worldwide
great depression
this is you know
my last resort but this is my guaranteed
survival system
i've got half a dozen of these drawn
over the next 200 miles up to almost 9
000 feet my plan is to retreat
ride it out and live to fight another
day that's what the spider hole is for
it survival's the goal it's into the
spider hole
and it's cozy in here
shelters made for missile silos and
shipping containers are designed for
long-term living
but doug has no intention of hunkering
down for that long although he can stay
in the spider hole for up to three days
at night he will return to his ranch to
take out the opposition
welcome to my trap said the spider to
fly
in the age of asymmetrical warfare
static fortress-like defenses can become
sitting ducks
that's why some preppers choose to go
mobile
professional welder riley cook built a
family-sized wagon to ford the rivers
and streams of colorado tim ralston
designed the solo trekker to haul
supplies or even a wounded comrade in
the arizona heat
but some preppers prefer a little more
horsepower
i'm preparing to survive the next great
depression caused by a worldwide
economic collapse
like snails and turtles martin and sarah
carry their bunker wherever they go
they live in prep out of the 50 square
foot sleeper cab in martin's big rig
truck
hi welcome to our home
it's the size of many americans master
closets and they have packed every last
inch of it with their important supplies
i've got stuff stashed just about
everywhere i can stash it in here
after the collapse
there's not going to be factories
i'm going to be able to make clothes i
have a stash of
dry food and i have two layers of it
behind this cabinet
we have approximately four to six months
worth of food in the truck
we stock up on our prescription meds by
maybe skipping a day or two a month
they can't stay mobile 24 7 and martin
will have to pull over to rest since
they can't bury their truck they plan on
hiding it
my little brother who is actually bigger
than i am
we call him red
red is retired from the air force you're
backed in pretty good with uh
concealment
he taught me many good things about what
i need to look at as a mobile prepper
the main objective is to conceal from
the roadway and so we're going to set up
some camouflage netting
over the front and the sides that are
exposed to any kind of roadway traffic
to mix in
with the local foliage
martin believes that with their unusual
mobile lifestyle for he and his wife to
survive when they stop moving they must
go undetected
if you can take the time
and exercise
in the coming collapse you can survive
it
you may have to run you may have to
fight somebody physically and if you're
a fat ass
you may get in there and bounce them
with your belly and then you're going to
have a vapor lock otherwise known as a
heart attack
been there done that didn't like it
so you want to try and at least allow
yourself the chance to survive
to survive in a world that they believe
will have no supermarkets many preppers
store food from floor to ceiling but
some have prepared themselves and their
children to eat just about anything you
gonna eat it
sure
preppers clearly understand that without
food and water they will die
the average body needs 2 000 calories
per day to function at a minimum level
food equals survival and without an
adequate supply of carbohydrates
proteins and fats the human body will
resort to cannibalizing its own tissue
this is stir fry
uh we've got crock pot
right here so who wants some groundhog
all right
to properly stockpile food for future
use the storage space must be cool dark
and dry
since her husband does not approve of
her prepping janet spencer has hidden
her extensive food stores in every nook
and cranny of her home
doug huffman stores enough food in his
underground root cellar to last him for
years
[Music]
but there are those preppers like john
major who do not have massive food
stores he is teaching his family to live
solely off the land for their doomsday
diet
i am prepping for a series of dirty bomb
attacks
look at that
so here you have the chicory
all right check under that one
anything
oh there's a cricket you gonna eat it
um sure
tastes like frozen cricket
it's like crunchy and then it is like
cream filled
yeah it's pretty pretty good
on average each cricket supplies his
children with 13 grams of protein the
ability to survive with nearly nothing
gives you a lot of freedom there are six
basic emotions humans feel
disgust is the only one that children
learn by watching the reactions of their
parents and the culture they're raised
in
my family gets a kick out of eating the
bugs grab me the cricut i am trying out
a new recipe on my crickets with onion
probably cover them with a little
parmesan cheese
mmm you it's really in my
mouth nowadays actually pretty good
even when i was giving my answer to him
for the prom he was coming out of the
field with his gun and i knew what i was
getting into i guess from the beginning
but not too many families go and eat
bugs together as a family activity by
normalizing the ideas of insects as food
foraging for them during a disaster will
seem like an everyday activity for
john's children
kaylee would you grab me a handful more
of crickets please
is this bug stew
we're gonna turn the mealworms into a
big meal
whoa look at the huge one
that one's mine
besides being high in protein insects
offer b vitamins and minerals like iron
and zinc as health benefits
they are often described as tasting
nutty
crunchy i cook my insects because
i do have some standards for taste
insect parmesan
a lot of other kids think it's weird to
eat bugs
but i think it's nummy
to simply survive you need calories and
vitamins but food plays another
important role it can boost morale
mike mester's family has stored away
jars of their favorite comfort food
meatloaf to get them through bad times
and it's quite tasty mr wayne is storing
enough food so he and his dog max will
survive an economic collapse
although they will never share the same
tastes they might have to share the same
food
but colleen bishop takes the cake she
has spent nearly 20 years preparing and
storing to be able to cook more than
eight years of gourmet last suppers
i am preparing for a financial collapse
which will result in the end of the
world as we know it
[Music]
i think i might be eating a little
differently than other preppers because
i'm a foodie everything i have i have
for full flavor and gourmet foods if the
world comes to an end i may be eating
rice and beans but they will be some
kicking rice and beans
i'll be eating more things like beef
stroganoff
chicken poppy seed casserole cocoa van
for cheese italian risotto i'll be
eating some good stuff
colleen believes the value of the dollar
will decrease so much that staple foods
will become expensive luxury items
this is where we store all of our yummy
freeze-dried and dehydrated foods
just this closet alone we have enough
for about eight people for three years
colleen has mastered the art of jarring
and canning she preserves even the most
perishable foods and then unconcerned
with refrigeration stores them all over
her house
we're running out of room for the canned
chicken
this one won't fit there's meat stored
all over the place
it's like oh excuse me don't step on the
meat under a doomsday scenario i'll be
the only one standing there who has
another hundred pounds to lose everybody
else will be skin and bones i'm grateful
for a wife that likes to and is good at
cooking okay
it's something that gives you an edge in
a doomsday scenario
colleen and scott know that in their
community if they are the only ones with
food stores they will not survive very
long they believe it is important to
teach others how to prepare meals with
shelf-stable foods
i might add just a couple pats of butter
because batter always makes uh the sauce
how old are these eggs they're about
seven eight months here's to eating well
at the end of the world even over food
and shelter the us military prioritizes
water as the most important tool for
survival survival can hinge on knowing
your closest water supply and having a
reliable filtration method although
fearing an avian flu pandemic laura
kunzi knows how to filter water from her
neighborhood
and kelly have a private source in their
own backyard
their hot tub
i am preparing for a collapse of
civilization
due to an electromagnetic pulse kind of
looks like i was drinking beer last
night there's a head on that
there it is folks
if their municipal water supply breaks
down steve and martha pace plan to
filter their own urine using a portable
charcoal water filter
the charcoal is porous and catches
impurities as the liquid passes through
the filter which steve hopes will make
his urine safe to drink it's still got a
slight yellow tint to it that's a tinge
that's a far cry from what it was when
it came out as a sample what land yes
while it may seem dirty fresh urine is
sterile
a carbon-based filter can help to remove
uric acid and maybe most importantly
improve flavor i claim it's not urine
now now it is a
clear
almost clear clean purified
liquid water
mm-hmm it does i'm amazed
like chlorinated water
really that's simple
taste it just put it on your lips
if this was your last resort you're
going to do it to survive here's cheers
to last resort
[Music]
put a little bit of mineral oil on your
hands
and then slather it all over the egg
which is basically mimicking how they
already come out of the hen
not allowing oxygen to get through
and they will sit tight for about uh 9
to 12 months in a cool dry place this
goes fast it does
food water and shelter are the basics
for survival but preppers are always
ready to defend what is theirs or lose
it i would just try to help somebody
many preppers believe that since they
had the foresight to build bunkers
stockpile food and store water to
survive almost any apocalyptic event
they would immediately become prime
targets for those who did not prepare
they're thinking that i didn't get food
that i could go take it away from mr
wayne in a crisis situation with police
forces overwhelmed or unable to respond
preppers fear they will be left alone to
defend themselves what will you do when
there's no one there
[Music]
there are three specific types of guns
preppers feel that they must have in
their arsenal a semi-automatic for
long-range hunting a shotgun for
short-range property defense and a
handgun for close combat
but for some three guns is not enough
and they take their personal protection
to the extreme
north carolina prepper pat brabel owns
the basic three armaments rifle shotgun
and pistol but believes a few backups
are essential
i'm preparing for the downfall of
society through hyperinflation
there is
60 or 70
weapons that are in my safes
pat brabel is a prepper who feels that
protecting his preps is a priority he
keeps his personal arsenal in a secret
room in his barn
this first gun is an ar-15 223 camp 45
the whole barrel is a silence bolt
action rifle 30 out six that's just a
little 22 rifle it's a little old 38 i
use it for shooting snakes i don't like
snakes
the average attacker can cover 21 feet
in 1.5 seconds so pat has tricked out
his home so that he will be ready to
draw a bead on an attacker at a moment's
notice the nine millimeter with an ankle
holster it's made of sheepskin so it's
very comfortable just put it on strap it
on
uh nobody never know you have it wear it
to the mall you can wear it up town you
can wear it to walmart
but pat can fire only one of his
hundreds of guns at a time so if as he
fears his home comes under concerted
attack he will need to bring more
firepower to bear
feel good
what
an estimated 15 million women in the
united states own their own gun but for
pat it is more about lynette getting the
proper training to ensure that she can
handle everything from a 22 pistol to
this civilian version of an m16 oh my
wife is holding a ar-15
some believe the ar-15 is the perfect
semi-automatic weapon for women since
its limited recoil allows for more
effective shooting by less muscular
individuals
semi-automatic then we're going to fully
automatic which one do you want fully i
guess i'm not going to say i'm going to
clip it's got a 30 round clip in it
military specs pretty much
to remain an accurate shot it is
recommended that you practice using a
firearm at least once a week and to
train using moving targets since this
better recreates what it would be like
to encounter real attackers
arizona dad tim ralston follows these
principles when taking his sons for
target practice in the desert take this
rifle lock and load
we train as often as we can out in the
desert there's no restrictions like you
would have in a gun club so we're able
to do more real-life situation shooting
all right so what we're gonna do uh
balloons are gonna represent a good guy
and a bad guy all right the bad guy is
the red guy
nice shot go go go get him get him get
him
again
nice shot
but on this day he learned that even the
most experienced marksmen can have a
misfire
what happened
get a truck up and ready he's gotta get
the hospital
jim
him tim look at me
jim
as soon as tim's gun went off without
warning shooting his thumb the film
crew's emergency medic jessie ellerbee
took swift action
his thumb right between the two knuckles
had a wound to it it channeled out the
middle essentially it's still connected
or you blew it yeah it's still
connecting we evac to a helicopter
went to the hospital they had me in
emergency surgery within like an hour of
me arriving it was one of those
malfunctions my thumb went in front of
the barrel and
it went off so now i basically left with
a little [ __ ] digit and uh it looks
the same it's just much much shorter
with no knuckle
but just a few weeks after the accident
tim was recuperating and no less
passionate about the importance of
prepping an emp does hit
it's going to get a lot worse than what
this thumb accident happened as a
prepper the most important tool is your
mind
preppers believe that having the right
hardware for defense is important but
having just the guns is worthless
without the proper tactical training
martin colville is a mobile prepper
so he can truck goods across the country
he his wife and his two dogs live out of
the cab of his 18-wheeler
he thinks that during desperate times
his truck and his cargo will become a
target of opportunity we have truck
hijackings that do occur when a collapse
occurs
big rigs will be considered freestanding
stores martin has enlisted his brother
red a defense consultant and former
member of the military to create a
crisis situation exercise so he can test
and improve his tactical training we're
going to see an 18-wheeler and they're
going to want what's in that 18-wheeler
now that we're actually doing this
hands-on exercise
he can better realize what he needs to
do ideal crisis simulations should be as
realistic as possible so they can be
used as a predictive and analytic tool
red has devised a scenario that he feels
will mimic an actual event that martin
might encounter on the road
by faking an accident red has created a
roadblock that gives martin two poor
choices leave his truck to try and clear
the path or turn his truck around either
scenario forces martin to stop which
immediately leaves him vulnerable to
ambush
yell out if you see something
keep an eye on them
see if you see anybody move
[Music]
are you injured
my leg
help me you behind the jeep i can see
your feet come on with your hands up
on the ground on the ground back up back
up put your weapon on
down on the ground
[Music]
i'm just trying to help that's wide out
arms straight
spread your legs
i was just trying to help somebody okay
martin feels realistic training
exercises are important because they
allow him an insight to his
decision-making process making him
better prepared when they actually
happen so what should i have done the
minute you see somebody there back away
my natural instinct is damsel in
distress post collapse hey it's you it's
sarah getting to your safe haven
thank you little brother not a problem
man i appreciate it
very very much
so you're never more than 20 feet away
from a firearm in this house one example
is a small firearm and a number 10 can
of peas
and i remember that because it's my pe
shooter
defense is a critical component of
preparing for doomsday but not every
prepper plans to rely on guns for
protection i suggest that we all run
redundancy is a basic tenet of prepping
having backups for their backups so if
guns break down or gunpowder becomes
scarce many preppers feel they need a
plan that goes beyond bullets
tim ralston designed and built the
krovel a multi-purpose tool that is
customized to open a beer bottle but
also if he needs to defend himself can
chop a man or a pig in half
in the backwoods of maine michael
douglas teaches his children to use an
american indian staple the tomahawk
because they are silent deadly and are
easily constructed from salvageable
material nice
i'm preparing for the yellowstone
national park super volcano to explode
for new york city firefighter jason
charles knives are the weapons of choice
jason lives in manhattan where handguns
are heavily restricted so instead he
owns over a dozen bladed weapons it's
always good self-defense weapon if you
know how to use it he believes knives
are superior to guns for city preppers
because they are lightweight legal and
ideal for close quarters combat
amerifist
to learn some basic knife fighting
techniques jason practices krav maga the
official self-defense system of the
israeli army with expert instructor
matan gavish if we come to a point where
we deal with the end of the world you
want to make sure you're on the lion
team in the jungle and not running
around with the gazelles
straight into here and that would that
would puncture the heart he will die
slowly and painfully
but surely
as a firefighter jason understands how
important practical training is so he's
asked matan to stage an attack in a more
limited space
open the door get into the house please
i have kids
[Music]
to create a sustainable food supply many
preppers add live animals to their
doomsday preparations
despite living in pasadena california
jules durvet maintains goats at his
suburban home
doug huffman raises rabbits
and names them after the recipes he will
use for his post doomsday cuisine this
is stir fry crock pot right here all
right we've got blackened but suburban
dad mike mester has no plans to make
meals out of his pets because they are a
crucial part of his home defense plan
two german shepherds storm and thunder
they're part of our family and they're
also part of our security like many
suburban house bets storm and thunder
have a cushy life but in preparation for
economic collapse in the ensuing civil
unrest mike fears he believes these
german shepherds natural instincts will
be important defensive assets one of the
things that i'd like to see if they're
capable of is providing a little bit
more security it's the training that
makes the difference it makes or breaks
the dog
it actually makes or breaks a
relationship with the family as well
come on come on
each of mike's german shepherds has a
natural fight drive proper training will
allow mike to control it
after some preliminary training the
mesters get a close-up demonstration of
what they hope storm and thunder could
become a trained attack dog
these dogs bite pretty hard it's not
something you want to take
without anything on
so in real life
you can lose something
okay
just stops on her command
one advantage of a dog is that unlike a
bullet they can always be called back
california prepper doug huffman has an
alternative defense plan he believes
that sometimes the best protection isn't
the fight but to hide
the most effective survival system is to
disappear
during the chaos and reappear
to just take back what you've lost
camouflage is doug's weapon of choice by
tricking the eye into perceiving color
and patterns as familiar objects such as
trees and fallen leaves or other natural
surroundings he is able to hide in plain
sight
doug has made over 30 camouflage ghillie
suits specifically crafted to mimic his
sierra nevada mountain terrain
you have to have the different colors to
fit your environment in
fall winter spring summer the grass has
changed the snow everything changes
appropriate camouflage is a difference
between life and death
texas prepper mr wayne plans on
protecting his ranch with more than just
bullets the culmination of his doomsday
defense plan ends with a bang
kids don't do this at home leave this to
the professionals only
very dangerous very very explosive mr
wayne knows how to make a pipe bomb
which can pack the explosive power of
eight sticks of dynamite each he
believes they are ideal perimeter
defense weapons because they are able to
disable or kill multiple invaders at
once
mr wayne plans to stop attackers with
the strategic placement of explosives
today he and his cousin jessie are going
to field test the blast radius of their
homemade pipe bombs
hang on to this for me while i get this
any unwanted visitor attempting to look
for safe cover on the property will find
a deadly surprise courtesy of mr wayne
you don't want to go too deep because
you want the shrapnel to tear him up too
i suggest that we all run
better get around here before it goes
off
come on
all right
it went off didn't it well looks like he
lost both of his legs yeah i don't think
he's going anywhere no tape a couple of
legs on him i think he'll be all right
a good way to stop any vehicle
is throwing out jacks
they'll puncture almost any tire
guns and bullets can only go so far if a
situation escalates out of control it is
time to get out of dodge
i'm bigger than you
any way they can
when disasters hit most prepper's
priority is to stay at home in their
community they will dig bunkers
stockpile food and arm themselves to the
teeth but when things escalate to a
point where they need to leave
this is called
bugging out
pulling out
preppers recognize the environment they
will cross dictates the mode of
transportation they will use
some use four-wheel drive to avoid
potentially dangerous crowds road debris
and survive extreme weather while others
choose less conventional modes of
transportation
i'm prepping for an emp attack resulting
in total chaos and riots
barry is prepared to bug into the urban
foxhole he built beneath his garage but
his family can only hide in there for so
long before their supplies run out if it
goes past 60 days we'll we'll make our
way to sea because i think you stand a
much better chance surviving at sea
than you do on land barry and his family
plan to bug out on foot to a sailboat he
keeps on puget sound
60 days after the emp attack barry fears
the 17 500 people living in barrie
suburb won't have had electricity or
running water for two months
so barry is prepared to navigate a
potentially volatile environment
the safest way to ever move when you're
in danger is to move it dark
that's why uh special forces operate at
night that's why the military operates
at night the cover of darkness can be
your best friend let's cut across this
way the family travel in single file
because it allows them to naturally
camouflage themselves in darkness they
appear as one person from the front and
rear we'll be able to kind of creep
silently we'll be dressed in dark
clothing we're not going to be easily
noticeable
and just as dawn breaks they reach the
boat yard
from here they will head to the nearest
uninhabited islands and set up a
temporary camp i have a couple of
islands that are completely uninhabited
in the north puget sound and will
immediately set sail for one of those
so do we look all clear bear
everything looks great
[Music]
many preppers have a variety of vehicles
for their bug out plan
but one prepper choice is a school bus
because they are designed to protect
children and can roll over and still
keep the interior intact
school buses are built to exacting
government standards and are among the
safest vehicles on the road
let's go let's go we're bugging out
i'm a prepper because i'm preparing for
when it's the fan
paul range is retired from his corporate
job and lives with his wife gloria
outside of floresville texas
all right guys let's get going let's go
let's go we're bugging out
we're running a drill to make sure that
we can load up in under an hour
and bug out they drive specially
customized bug out vehicles
second-hand school buses we've got a
house sitting on wheels
we took all the seats but a few out all
right guys we have 55 minutes to get the
bus loaded up let's get going those cans
those cans
today they are running a drill to see if
they can exit their compound with their
animals approximately 10 000 pounds of
food and 310 gallons of water in under
an hour we believe that we can survive
for about 10 years with what we're going
to take with us
come on goats we're bugging out
our animals are actually trained
to bug out come on
come on goats
hurry hurry hurry
we've got water we've got food and
kitchen equipment we've got the medical
supplies we're ready to go
go go go go go
pulling out
the convoy of buses will travel to a
pre-designated safe point two and a half
hours from the compound and from there
they will go to their final and secret
destination
we have a specific time of the day
that we are going to leave because we
want to move through some areas in the
dark and we want to move through some
areas in the daylight we can get to
anywhere within the state without having
to actually pass through a big city
one of the things
that makes excellent bandage material
that's very cheap is
maxi pads and tampons they're built for
absorbing blood they're very absorbent
they're sterile
so i stock up on a lot of those
in extreme emergency situations preppers
will bug out using any means necessary
land sea or air believing that they'll
have only one chance to make it and
survive
my feet feel like they're about to fall
off my ankles
when it comes to making a successful bug
out the terrain population and weather
are all factors that will determine the
exact plan
megan hurwitz knows that even in the
best of times her hometown of houston
has traffic problems
so she is foregoing a car and relying on
her own two feet
i'm preparing for a catastrophic oil
crisis
megan plans to bug out on foot she
believes all motorized transportation
will be useless making houston's 50 000
miles of roadways a parking lot
i'm going to mexico
with her backpack a map and a supply of
water megan plans to hike to a car
hidden close to the mexican border and
avoid the 2.7 million vehicles that
could be stuck in a panic
it's gonna be 10 to 12 miles depending
upon what i have to go around and what
obstacles i'm gonna have to travel
through
the best time to do this would be right
at dusk
that way i'll have enough cover of
darkness
but i'll still be able to see
there's a good chance there won't be any
power so i'll be
completely in the dark for the most part
soldiers in afghanistan carried around
100 pounds with them on patrol in a
crisis situation megan will be carrying
nearly half that amount so to prepare
megan spends four hours a day six days a
week in training she knows she won't
make the trip unless she's in peak
physical condition if i hurry i can be
there in three hours
if there's blockades it could take me
all the way to four or five
when i do this for real
all this is gonna be dark
some of the sketchy areas i was a little
worried about getting mugged
it's happened to me before it could
happen again
i could handle myself
you do
should always carry a spare pair on you
kind of getting tired
ah this pack's getting a little heavy
my feet feel like they're about to fall
off my ankles
so it's been a long
long six hours
hike uh took twice as long as i thought
it was going to
all right i'm exhausted but i'm losing
time and i'm almost there
not much further
i'm by no means an expert at any of this
stuff
even with all the preparation and all
the skill sets i'm trying to learn and
all the foresight that i'm putting into
prepping to hit the fan next week i
probably wouldn't make it
hits the fan in five years i'll probably
be okay
preppers and mountainous areas like
jeremy's family often want a bug out
vehicle that can handle the extremely
difficult terrain
i'm preparing for the collapse of
society due to peak oil
jeremy and his wife kelly live in utah
at the foot of the rockies
they believe that an impending oil
crisis will send america into chaos
if that happens they plan to head to the
mountains in the last thing that anyone
would expect during a gas shortage a
retired army truck which jeremy calls
the beast we do need to get out of town
we do need to leave our home and flee
we have a vehicle to do so in the m35 is
a favorite transport vehicle of the us
army it can carry 5000 pounds of cargo
off-road and up to ten thousand pounds
on-road
m-35 trucks are designed to run on a
variety of fuels besides gasoline jeremy
plans to use discarded motor oil
it's shelter it's also
transportation it's got a huge
compartment we can put all of our water
we can put all of our food we can put
the bunk bed in there have a place to
sleep and
really shelter our family in
you want to learn to drive this thing i
sure do i think it'd be fun it's an army
truck from the 70s it doesn't have power
steering it doesn't have all the smooth
transmission
shifting gears that our average vehicles
do mommy's gonna drive how scary is that
huh
all right let's do this
let's go do some donuts out here in this
dirt field
here we go we're going off-road
yeah baby
xander's sleeping through it all
sorry buddy aggressively
that was awesome
with enough alternative fuel stockpiled
to take them 1 000 miles jeremy and
kelly can bug out to almost anywhere
they choose as long as i've got my son
on my lap and my husband in the driver's
seat that's all i need
while no one is 100 sure of when the end
of days will arrive as preppers go to
these great extremes and make enormous
sacrifices to prepare for doomsday one
thing becomes clear they plan to survive
i think that you need to be responsible
for yourself and for your family and to
do anything less is a criminal act are
you gonna sit back and wait for the
cavalry
they may never come we all hope for the
best but prepare for the worst with
murphy's law
murphy said anything that can go wrong
will go wrong
how likely are the events featured in
this program
most scientists economists and military
leaders feel that in the immediate
future the cataclysmic events described
in this show remain highly unlikely
however government officials do
recommend taking steps to ensure
personal preparedness to cope with
unanticipated events and disasters
[Music]
you